nötig ist aber auf jeden fall haben
jetzt voll wechsel schon und ja jetzt
zeige ich euch einfach mal gucken hier
jetzt gesehen habe diesen sound gehört
ich hätte theoretisch fall schaden
bekommen aber ich bin zehn sekunden
gegen jeglichen schaden immun
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen kit vorstellung ihr wisst
bescheid ich habe gesagt wenn ihr die
kit vorstellung wollt dann mache ich die
euch ich habe extrem viele kommentare
geschrieben
quasi jeder zweite kommentar unter dem
letzten video war so einer jahr noch mal
eine vorstellung bietet vorstellung und
ich denke mir natürlich mache ich doch
gerne gerade weil ich jetzt auch wieder
so meinen spaß ein ende games
wiederfinde
wir gehen einfach mal eine runde rein
und zwar will euch heute folgen des kit
vorstellen wir schauen mal den
teleporter zack ausgewählt der
teleporter hat den folgen der verkürzte
seitlich mal vorlesen weil die runden
echt schnell starten hier der teleporter
den effekt dass er mit jedem kind voll
geheilt wird das heißt immer wenn er
geschwächt werde wenn dieses buch kommt
oder einem anderen ort seid dann habt
ihr volle leben plus ihr seid zehn
sekunden nach dem switch unverwundbar
das ist eine ziemlich geile sache echt
cool ich habe jetzt ein bisschen an
gespielt wir machen es einfach mal die
vorstellung und schauen wie wir in
dieser runde jetzt das kind einsetzen
können die runde geht in 20 sekunden los
sie kann glaube ich nicht mehr fußball
nicht 7 statt
also wir verbinden v3 service gesehen
aber wir können die runde nicht manuell
starten scheinbar sondern automatisch an
das geht computer luther liegt wie die
das jagd die dia ziemlich dasselbe deute
das auf jeden fall schon mal ein schöner
schwert jetzt müssen wir aufpassen sonst
kein känguru überholt oder kalender
telefons wirft damit wir auch nen paar
kisten bekommen weil nur zwei das ist
nicht das allerbeste sehr gut da ist
noch eine hak noch mal die ist nämlich
gerne mit uns wird ja alles klar
zack so
es war das denn gerade für ein geräusch
ich arbeite einfach so ein
da drüben da drüben sonic ist sehr gut
holen oder wollen und ja wie gesagt
teleporter hat mir sehr gut gefallen im
allgemeinen die neuen kids gefallen war
alles ziemlich gut von der beschreibung
her
deswegen würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
auch lust auf weitere kind vorstellung
es könne ja natürlich in die kommentare
schreiben
und ich würde sagen wenn ihr bock drauf
habt und euch die kit vorstellung
gefallen die ich jetzt machen mit den
kids dann können wir gerne noch einige
davon machen weil ich echt langsam
wieder richtig spaß einer games
hauptstadt leider nicht mehr ändern
games gespielt aber mittlerweile kommt
der van wieder zurück sagt wir haben die
ihr schwert können wir sonst was machen
wir machen uns mal lederschuhe damit wir
falls jemand sich hoch steckt nicht
sterben
ihr wisst ja wenn man es nie krieg
maximal fünf herzen fall schaden und da
vorne ist der erste gegner ist ein
känguru das ein känguru dafür muss man
den speed blockiert dieses känguru zu
überraschen
dieses kängurus überraschend da ist er
da ist einer dessen rudi laufen auch
schnell laufen sehr schnell aber wir
können ihn erwischen und attacke ja sehr
gut seitlichen hingegeben trennen immer
ein bisschen von seinem ziel
ja da ist er down und noch einer down
sehr gut schon der zweite akt zeigt es
geht weiter da fordert den schnappen wir
uns hätte auch schuhe hier wo es
passiert was passieren um gott oh mein
gott wer seinem blog okay ist ist es der
liga vor uns weggelaufen ist ich weiß es
nicht
wir haben noch nicht gegeben da kommt er
wieder und wir haben ihn sehr gut sehr
gut sehr gut sehr bedeutend richtig gut
hier und jetzt haben wir auch ein paar
rüstungs passiert wenn man anziehen
können können es auch welche kräften das
zimmer so an
der gegner kommt auch schon eher das
heißt wir uns beeilen wenn ich wollen
dass er uns gilt noch als gold haben
mich gerade so usa 7 5 474 blöcke ist
noch nicht so nah wie rücken aus leute
wir rücken aus 50 39 730 kommt näher
kommt näher
ist es ein schaf ist sich und schaaf
nein da ist werde ich ihn von hinten er
als nicht sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut
sehr gut sehr gut das war sauber ja ich
hab wohl jetzt noch gar nicht verletzt
vielleicht zeige ich euch einfach mal
kurz in dem ich mich jetzt mal kurz
selbst anzünden oder wir warten einfach
ab
ich werde ich noch kurz demonstrieren
dass man starke kippt der ist stark
getrübt
schauen wir dass wir dem fc porto jetzt
geben können ja da war noch ein treffer
um treffer hinterher osterwasser zacken
schwerte
ich hatte mich richtig gerne eine
rüstung kollege selbst davon gibt es mit
diplomatie viel schaden ach du scheiße
meine fresse steckte viel ein das gibt
es ja nicht
das ist ja irre wie viel schaden
einstecken kann heute hat und es gesehen
so viele schwert hitz the hammer
keine ahnung was man gegen den machen
soll also ganz ehrlich der so viel
eingesteckt unfassbar
keine ahnung was das war leute ich weiß
es nicht wir machen auf jeden fall in
kurzen card und sehen uns in der
nächsten runde wieder biss da ich so
dass ihr wieder die runde startet in
drei sekunden immer noch das teleporter
kind und wieder schauen dass wir einen
guten fight gegen ok wenn die kiste
komplett geflutet um alles raus bekommen
aber die map ist jetzt nicht so gut hier
für leute die keinen bewegungs kit haben
extrem hohe berge im leider keine
änderten wir haben nicht das känguru
geht das heißt wir können jetzt einfach
nur ja sozusagen lang wachsen und hoffen
dass wir entlang unseres weges die alle
andere kiste finden
seht ihr eine anna davor nach vorne ist
ab davon ist kommen wir da hin
da kommen wir hin und zwar so und ja
sehr gut fünf weisen jetzt fünf weisen
drei gold andersherum wäre es ehrlich
gesagt ein bisschen besser kann man
schwer zu machen und den goldhelm wo
kommst du denn
ok ok 30 sekunden was willst du jetzt
hast du jetzt vor verstehe ich jetzt
nicht ganz aber okay jetzt ein bisschen
um uns herum geschlecht ein bisschen rum
getigert wollte mal schauen wer das so
ist
ja das war glaube ich nicht erkannt
beigelegt sind hat eigentlich kann das
heute nicht erkennen wenn jetzt keine
rolle wenn es nur ein eisen schwert aber
die hatte auch nur gold wert heißt
vielleicht können wir die überraschen
bis da unten ist keine kiste da hinten
sich noch einer frau oder kommerz recht
auch nicht hin wo die schützer des
landes geht los leute es geht los
wir ernähren uns so key treffen die man
hier die hatte eine leder rüstung nichts
zu donners aber immerhin leder immer in
rüstung und die musik nicht ob ich nicht
kommen
nein soll er doch ja die ist alles
klappt dann haben wir hier das auge über
die hälfte unserer herzen verloren
heftig und jetzt noch mehr weil ich
darunter falle oft die chance hast du
bist ja noch was ein bisschen auf so
sagt essens das rein
wir essen uns das rein deutsch oder so
ich gehört nicht sondern bei mir ich hab
gar den deutschen messen keinen bogen
kein feuerzeug ja zuerst gesehen hab
jetzt gesehen heute die herzdamen sich
komplett wieder aufgefüllt wir sind
wieder komplett regeneriert er war davor
ziemlich ramponiert da ist irgendwo
schon mal ein gegner eingeholt besserung
selig ich sehe dich selig
ich sehe dich und du bist da und zack
ist so lustig mittlerweile fliegen da
immer die die sozusagen die körper der
getöteten immer noch bisschen so das
bild und bist selbst im ausland auf
einmal noch ein typ da ist und da lang
step denkt man schon so das war's für
mich aber nein weil du ihn schon getötet
haben so wird auch ein feuerzeug alles
klar
kriterium zwar nicht einparken doch nur
holz und wir gehen jetzt mal auf mai fcb
da vorne ist er sowieso nicht meine
sache
falten zwar davon 1
und sehr schön floor lässt hatten sich
getroffen er war wohl auch an grauen
angeschlagen schon who
gott sei dank haben wir gerade dass eine
krippe durchsucht von sad ist uns jetzt
ziemlich böse erwischt können es aber
auf jeden fall mal einen goldwert machen
diesen schuh müssen uns klarmachen
wollte dann haben wir nämlich auch schon
mal zumindest was schuhe und
kopfbedeckung angeht weisen die
wunderpille dahin hoffentlich jetzt
klatschen setzt sich gegen die wand
bekannt dass behinderte wenn man
entwirft und die klatschen und so gegen
irgend gewandt weil man nicht richtig
richtig nicht hoch genug drauf hat oder
nicht gut gezielt und man fällt einfach
runter plus krieg noch zwei herzen
schaden für den teleport dann ist man
ziemlich am arsch meistens muss noch was
essen wir haben den bogen nicht der fall
schade aber wir haben immerhin man die
erschwert werden ein bisschen rüstung
und wir haben das teleporter geht und
wir haben uns jetzt wieder komplett
aufgefüllt werden glaube ich ein
bisschen schade und wie es ist jetzt
auch kurz immun das wird hier im
inventar nicht angezeigt der effekt aber
man ist immun alte marke dann
beispielsweise keinen fall schaden
ich werde euch einfach mal zeigen wenn
ich gesund werde versuche ich einfach
mal worunter zu springen aber eigentlich
ordentlich fall schon bekommen sollte
all das war schade
genau in dem moment und was steffen keth
oh oh oh oh oh glück gehabt glück gehabt
glück gehabt wer bisschen weiter weg
hätte uns echt übel zu spielen können
wir so im bogen wir sehr gut doch mal
wieder auf und gucken was sich jetzt
sonst auch so ergibt eisen schuhe hatte
die sonstigen was wir brauchen können
schade wir haben nicht so viel reisen
wenn man nicht so um einen diamanten
können uns jetzt deswegen leider nicht
hier wie groß das equipment kräften das
bisschen eisen
jetzt können wir waren sehr gut
mannschaft wettmachen
sehr gerne 740 blöcke von ist der
nächste
bei uns stimmt
ja ok erst als der tat in der eisen
leggins und wir warten darauf dass wir
geschwitzt werden gesetz da unten wir
haben ziemlich viel schaden bekomme ich
es trotzdem an april will ich
regeneriere oder zwei äpfel äpfel sind
gesund ihr wisst bescheid nimmer dass
ihr weg dass ihr weg dass ihr weg dass
ihr weg damit wir die eisenrose bekommen
und bisher leider nur eine lederhose so
alles klar
okay von ibm und wir können ausdrücken
154 blöcke bis zum nächsten ist der
letzte und das war auch relativ still
ich mir diese runde asus mit gewinnen
könnten ja und ich zumindest ein
bisschen braucht man noch relativ
sportlich durch die landschaft bewegen
weil er ziemlich schnell hunger fall
schaden unnötigste er war unnötig aber
auf jeden fall haben jetzt voll wechsel
schon und ja jetzt zeige ich euch
einfach mal gucken hier hab's gesehen er
bis in sound gehört
ich hätte theoretisch fall schaden
bekommen aber ich bin zehn sekunden
gegen jeglichen schaden immun und das
ist unter unter anderem deswegen weil
man wenn man dann geortet wird nicht
überrascht werden kann
bis ihr wenn man gepostet wird und auf 1
steht man wird mich jemand getauscht
gerade mit jemand anderem im kampf ist
man wird auf einmal geschlagen dann
stirbt man gerne mal also das ist oft
durch jeder der ender ganz spielt hat
das mal erlebt dass er gefordert wird
und dann einfach stört weil der gegner
da ist das kann mit dem teleporter
kippen nicht passieren weil ihr eben
zehn sekunden gegen jeglichen schaden
immun sein und zwar nicht nur gegen
kampf schaden sondern wie wir gesehen
haben auch gegen fall schaden das ist
ziemlich cool zum beispiel es alter das
geht es ja richtig gut das ist auch
dafür gut wenn jemand sich hoch trauert
wenn jemand turmbauten jede runterfallen
solange nicht länger als zehn sekunden
fall kriegt er auch keinen schaden hat
er uns gesehen
das wilde was will denn auf weg verläuft
was ist dein plan was hast du vor lass
mich doch einfach mal die runde gewinnen
wie wär's ja wir sind wie könnte ich
getroffen wie könne nicht getroffen wenn
ihr habt es gesehen und das teleport
paket hat uns den sieg beschert sehr gut
genau noch mal getauscht geworden
das gibt einen jiji ihr seht maxis
account schöne runde hat mir echt gut
gefallen
die leute wird sich auch gefallen hat
dann könnt ihr einen like da lassen
können in die kommentare schreiben
welche kitze in der nächsten folge sehen
wollt ich werde mir die kommentare durch
und dann werdet ihr auch erwähnt im
nächsten video wenn ihr das wollt mir
hat echt spaß gemacht ich hoffe ich auch
ehrlich sagen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video